all right so this is an iPhone 15 and a
15 plus and a 15 Pro and a 15 Pro Max
every new phone in the lineup new colors
new materials New Ports there's some
good stuff to unbox here so let's do it
so starting with iPhone 15 and 15 plus
this iPhone 15 here is the new blue
color and it is
I'm just going to go ahead and rename
this color to barely blue I think that's
an appropriate name because it really is
barely giving hints of blue you can
really see it on the side rails too but
yeah really subtle colors across the
board this year anyway the other things
in the Box are the paperwork the single
white Apple sticker and there is no SIM
card ejector tool here since they're all
esim at least in the US now but most
importantly the new cable in the iPhone
box for all new iPhones is a single
white braided USB C to usb-c Cable I
think this is the first time the iPhone
is shipping with a braided nice cable
like this so hopefully it'll be a higher
quality and more durable than gold
cables we've been getting for years so
cool USBC cable USBC phone now if we
take a look at the plus same idea a
bigger box but this new incredibly pale
yellow I mean again in perfect lighting
at the Apple event I think it looked a
little bit more colorful but it just
looks extremely pale out here and then
we've got the pro boxes for the pro
phones as well still White boxes but
dark wallpapers so the iPhone 15 Pro I
have here is the new dark blue color I
almost want to call this one barely blue
again but this time it's darker and kind
of borders on Gray when the light hits
it from certain angles very safe same
stuff in the box after that though the
paperwork the white Apple sticker and
the new braided usb-c cable and then our
iPhone 15 Pro Max here is the new
natural titanium color and I gotta say
guys I think this is going to be the one
to get this it's the best color in
person in the hand I'll talk more about
why in a minute but there you have it
the slightly new unboxing experience on
iPhone 15s and 15 Pros so by the time
you see this I've been testing these
phones for about six days now not quite
enough time for a review by my standards
but still plenty of time to give you
some interesting thoughts some things
that I've picked up on and some quirks
so first of all these pale colors I
don't really know how else to say it
like this might be totally fine with you
I always get told everyone's gonna put a
case on their phone which they probably
probably are but hey Apple did spend a
ton of time and money making this new
softer touch satin finish on the back
and some of us some of us will carry our
phones around with no case so it's worth
mentioning for the pro phones there's
actually an extra layer of interesting
though because they've switched that
rail material the part that you actually
touch on the outside from shiny
stainless steel to brushed titanium
we've all heard about how much lighter
it is and it's something like 10 lighter
which is enough for me to notice and
enjoy but the other thing is I thought
the brushed finish would sort of
eliminate fingerprints on the sides
absolutely not I was wrong about that I
mean it's less it's not as bad as
stainless steel but especially on these
darker colors like the black or this
blue you can totally see fingerprints
and sort of wear your hand oils are
marking up the sides of the phone and
then on top of that this is not anodized
like aluminum might be this is the new
PVD coating they talked about on stage
and it's only been a week here for me
and so I don't know exactly how well
this will hold up over time but what I
do know is if you get a scratch deep
enough into this coating it's got to be
the natural titanium color underneath
which is very light and so that might
look rough if you if you drop this phone
with no case and get like a big gash on
your dark colored phone and have light
marks all over it all that to say I I do
really think that this natural Titanium
or the light is going to be the better
color to get on the pros this year okay
some things I've noticed in my first
week so first of all on the pro the
bezels are technically a little bit
thinner which makes the buys a little
smaller but you really don't notice that
much after a few minutes what you do
notice more actually visually is the
slightly softer curves all the way
around these phones seriously on the 15
and 15 Pro because on the 14 it was so
square like it just went straight to the
edge with a flat display and then it
dropped right into the rail at 90
degrees on these new phones the edge of
the front glass actually has a little
bit of curve at the very edges so it's a
softer curve into the rail then the rail
itself has softer curves than the
totally sharp corners from last year so
I think it's a nice hybrid of making it
just more comfortable in the hand with
these curves but still keeping the
generally boxy look now with USBC on
these phones we already learned that you
can just plug in a cable to charge an
accessory right so you it's no reverse
wireless charging but you can at least
plug in a USBC cable straight to airpods
or an Apple Watch magsafe charger
whatever and it will charge from your
phone's battery so that's all already
pretty interesting but I decided it's
worth learning all the rules and
behaviors of plugging things into the
iPhone 15s so here they are so if you
plug in any older lightning iPhone into
a USBC iPhone regardless of the charge
State the USBC iPhone will always give
battery to the lightning iPhone every
single time no matter what now if you
plug in another USBC iPhone into your
USBC iPhone it actually does a handshake
where they talk to each other figure out
which one has the lower battery and then
the one with the higher stated charge
goes all right I'm a battery bank and I
will start charging the one with the
lower stated charge all the way till you
unplug it so I thought that was pretty
interesting and it works pretty well
then I decided to try a couple of
Android phones and see if the same
handshake happened basically what we
found is if you plug into your friend's
Android phone who has more battery than
you and that phone has USB PD it will
actually act like a battery bank but if
the phone doesn't have USB PD which is a
bunch actually right now it's pretty
inconsistent and you can end up charging
it or it could end up charging you
literally unplug and try it again but if
it has USB power delivery it will
actually do the same handshake that the
iPhones do it's only four and a half
Watts out so it's not huge it's not
going to fast charge or anything but you
know it is ideal for accessories you can
literally use the cable in the Box to
charge up the new airpods or whatever
else you want to try but yeah you can
rescue another smartphone in a pinch so
then the new action button on the pros I
was very curious about this I was I was
not sure if it would have some
restrictions or if there's some things
that it wouldn't let you do and it turns
out
I haven't been able to find any so far
it seems like it basically lets you do
anything you want and I am very happy
about that I mean this was a feature of
a lot of Android phones in the past
there were some LG phones that did this
some Sony phones I want to say some Asus
phones I'm hoping it starts to make a
bit of a comeback here because on this
new iPhone it is great so you jump into
the settings and go to action button and
it loads up this whole crazy UI that's
just like nothing like any of the other
settings pages on the iPhone like they
just stapled this in here but okay and
as I showed you in The Impressions video
you can do any number of pre-programmed
things with this button by default it is
still the mute switch that it replaces
and it has those two different haptic
patterns so when you mute it in your
pocket you know exactly what you're
doing without even checking you did it
correctly but honestly I don't know I
leave my phone on mute most of the time
anyway so you can also have it open up
the camera in any of the camera modes
but then again the camera shortcut is
like right on your lock screen already
and I'm pretty used to that same thing
with the flashlight you could do that
but it's also already on everyone's lock
screen screen I like the voice memo
trigger it's actually pretty convenient
because it immediately starts recording
when you press and hold the button but
my favorite by a mile is the series
shortcuts function because it basically
lets you do anything else you can have
it you can stack up a bunch of different
functions that are like location
dependent or you can have it call a
certain contact or do certain things or
if you just want to literally open any
app on your phone with zero lag so it
could be your to-do list app or your
calendar app or just open YouTube with
any one button press whatever you want
for me I'm going to map my action button
on my brand new iPhone to the Google
Assistant the best assistant available
on the iPhone also Apple if you're
listening I also wish you could map a
double press or a triple press of the
action button to a new specific function
just think about it also I was kind of
curious how cases would handle this new
action button so I asked Channel sponsor
dbrand to send over their new ghost case
and I have it here personally pretty
solid I think this matte black skeleton
design looks sick and yes I can confirm
that even with the case the action
button still feels nice and clicky now
you might be thinking all right what's
so special about this clear case I've
seen a million clear cases and between
the skeleton and magsafe if there's a
bunch of other stuff but my favorite
personally is if you've ever owned a
clear case before you probably know that
after a while it kind of ends up looking
like this just disgusting and yellow but
dbrand has promised me that they've
specifically engineered the ghost case
to be impossible to Yellow
and they use those words themselves so
they actually give you like a lifetime
case replacement guarantee if it ever
yellows so that's either a real promise
or free cases for life the way I see it
either way if you're interested I'll
leave a link below the like button if
you want to check it out that's the
dbrand ghost case now I've also been
taking some pictures and videos with
these new cameras to get a sense of how
they perform I will be taking many many
more posting them on on Twitter if you
want to follow me there Instagram as
well I also fully plan on shooting the
next autofocus car Channel video with
this phone so you already know you can
go subscribe over there to see how the
video looks to hear how the microphones
sound one thing that they did mention in
the keynote specifically was there was a
new coating over the lenses that I
immediately thought oh does this fix the
horrible night time flare issues with
the iPhone's video first thing I did was
go to a dark room bring it out at night
shoot with some lights no it didn't fix
it unfortunately I'm sure the coding
does some other great stuff during the
daytime but there's still flare issues
sadly but also lastly I want to clarify
the new camera behavior on the pro
phones in The Impressions video I was a
little down on the whole like 1X versus
1.2x for versus 1.5 x thing because I
thought it was literally just a digital
crop which would be pretty pointless to
me but it's actually closer to a set of
super res Zoom presets that you can
actually then digitally Zoom between
I'll detail all this in the full reviews
and here's some benchmark scores in case
you're curious about that sort of thing
for performance for the a17 pro which is
actually new uh but generally I think
that wraps up my first
Second Impressions my second look now
that I got him in the studio really I
feel like the base iPhone 15s if you're
thinking if if you want to buy one of
these or pre-order them
it's a bigger Improvement than it seems
on paper like nothing is actually new
here
but because it's bringing things from
last year's Pro phone it's actually a
very solid phone and then the pro
it's a lot more interesting because
there's some genuinely new stuff
happening I've seen new stuff with the
cameras also it seems like someone found
out the batteries are slightly bigger
across the board which is good too we'll
see if that holds up but generally let
me know what you want to see in the full
reviews in the comment section below
because I will be working on those over
the next couple days and weeks and
hopefully you'll see that soon
either way thanks for watching catch in
the next one face
[Music]